bonsoir et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
journal de tv fil 78 nous sommes le
jeudi 26 février voilà ce que l'on peut
retenir dans l'actualité yvelinoise les
électeurs de voisins-le-bretonneux
devront retourner aux urnes au maximum
dans les trois mois qui viennent en
plateau dans quelques instants
alexandra rosetti actuel maire de la
commune et alexis piette qui avait
déposé le recours viendront s'expliquer
une fois par mois les entreprises
adhérentes de promo paul sont invités à
des réunions d'information
nous avons voulu faire le point sur la
situation alors que la procédure de
conciliation
cette faible dose avril les malades
atteints de lam et vidal de parkinson
souhaiteraient plus de professionnels de
santé formés à cette pathologie
c'est l'une des réflexions menées lors
de la dernière réunion et on est
marxiste selon l'un avec une page
politique ce mercredi 25 février la
décision du conseil d'état est tombé
faudra revoter à voisins le bretonneux
une décision qui peut surprendre
certains alors que le tribunal
administratif avait rejeté la demande
alexis piette ancien maire de la commune
et lui fait depuis 95 battu aux
dernières élections de mars 2014 de 15
voix alexis piette bonsoir je lui dis un
14 octobre 2014
le tribunal administratif avait rejeté
votre demande d'annulation des élections
le 12 novembre vous avez saisi le
conseil d'état qui vient vous donner
raison de faudra donc revoter à voisins
le bretonneux au motif que deux tracts
ont été diffusés le samedi du second
tour ce qui est formellement interdit
forcément ça vous donne satisfaction
cette décision écoutez je pense que ça
donne satisfaction aux vies si noir
parce que ils ont été trompés c'est donc
leur redonner la parole dans des
conditions qui cette fois ci je l'espère
seront égales pour tous si respectueuse
des lois
quelles ont été les réactions autour de
vous à l'annoncé de cette décision du
conseil d'état qui peuvent surprendre
puisqu'elle ne suis pas le ministre
hâtif c'est une décision exceptionnelle
un vous savez qu'est ce que c'est que le
conseil d'état
c'est la plus haute juridiction
administrative de notre république et
c'est assez vrai exceptionnel d'avoir
une annulation d'élection
donc ça montre que les faits sont graves
et qu'il y avait eu violation du code
électoral à de multiples reprises pour
vous avez lancé ces procédures le relief
ce fameux tract était qui a été diffusé
le vendredi 28 mars a donc à la veille
de l'élection
idem pour cet appel lancé sur facebook
le samedi 29 mars pour vous c'était
c'était un autre os pourquoi est ce que
on a réagi parce que il nous a semblé
qu'il y avait tromperie qu'il y avait
des irrégularités et après le premier
tour nous avons déposé un procès verbal
au commissariat de police pour signaler
ces erreurs là qui nous semblaient être
des irrégularités et avec les
témoignages que nous avons eues nombreux
le samedi et la semaine d'après
effectivement on a pu à ce moment-là
étayer ces suspicions on va dire et
déposer tout de suite un recours et le
recours devant le tribunal administratif
n'a pas abouti parce qu'il a été il a
été refoulé qu'est-ce qui a fait la
différence selon vous entre la décision
du tribunal administratif qui nous a dit
non il faut pas nous les élections et le
conseil d'état qui écoute et je ne je ne
sais pas un les tribunaux sont maîtres
de leurs décisions je ne sais pas qu'est
ce qui a prévalu au tribunal
administratif par rapport au conseil
d'état mais en tout cas c'est la
décision du conseil d'état qui prévaut
c'est la plus haute juridiction
administrative de notre république
certains disent que vous avez lancé ces
procédures notamment donc de notre
initiative devant le conseil d'état un
peu par esprit de revanche contre
alexandra rosetti qu'était votre
ancienne première adjointe
c'est un peu la guerre des droites à
voisins-le-bretonneux puisque
quand même du même bord politique tous
les deux alors bon on danse on verra sur
les sur les bords politiques je peux
vous annoncer maintenant ça serait la
santé car face à sion est ce que j'ai un
sentiment de revanche vous me demandez
je ne le crois pas vous savez je me suis
consacré à à cette fonction de maire
sans en faire une carrière politique je
n'ai jamais vraiment voulu faire autre
chose que cela
mais ce n'est pas non plus ma profession
j'ai une profession à côté oui tout à
fait je n'ai pas un métier mais enfin
c'est quand même j'en ai rien je n'ai
pas voulu en faire une carrière
politique comme on fera une carrière
professionnelle
donc je ne crois pas que ce soit un
sentiment qui m'habite c'est servir ma
ville ses habitants et mener une équipe
qui me fait confiance
le préfet des yvelines doit maintenant
signifier donc aux élus voisins moto ne
leur démission une délégation spéciale
ensuite être mises en place pour assurer
la gestion de la commune avant la tenue
d'élections qui devrait avoir lieu dans
les trois mois certains annoncent déjà
la date à peu près de dimanche 12 avril
pour le premier tour s'est pas confirmée
mais c'est en tout cas c'est ce qui se
dit est ce que vous serez vous candidat
pour ces nouvelles élections
écoutez nous verrons la décision du
conseil d'état vient de tomber
hier après midi c'est la logique donc ce
serait le candidat
écoutez c'est ce n'est pas automatique
en tout cas c'est quelque chose qu'il
faut peser mesurer et ça a toujours été
comme ça à chaque élection eh bien les
la question se repose et puis après
c'est l'équipe qui décide et bien son le
fera la même chose la semaine prochaine
alors que la semaine prochaine vous
donnerez votre décision malgré tout
qu'est ce qui vous fait hésiter
aujourd'hui à vous lancer dans une
campagne
ici parlent quand on est un ancien maire
qu'on a été battu de 15 voix on dépose
de recours 1,29 administratif devant le
conseil d'état
on se dit quand même que s'il ya des
nouvelles élections c'est pour repartir
ça ça paraît logique
qu'est ce qui vous fait hésiter mais
c'est pas un combat personnel c'est un
combat personnel c'est un c'est un
renouveau politique on est nommé c'est
un combat pour le respect des lois et
l'exemplarité du monde politique qui
vous le savez est bien décrié en ce
moment donc c'est plutôt ça qui m'a mis
qui m'anime c'est plutôt de faire
respecter les lois et qu'il y ait
égalité démocratique entre tous les
candidats l'aller les sinois ont été ont
été trompés et maintenant ça sera la
campagne sera là pour mettre développer
nos arguments et les villes chinoises se
prononceront en toute connaissance de
cause
c'est donc la semaine prochaine prendre
votre décision si vous êtes candidats
faisaient de tête de liste ça sera donc
la semaine prochaine après consultation
devrait vous faire réagir sur les
dernières élections municipales
partielles celle de louveciennes c'était
il ya quelques quelques semaines même
cas de figure
andré van beeck le maire de yutz yens
entre 2001 et 2014 avait été battu de 2
15 voix par pierre françois wiart le
tribunal admistratif avait annulé
l'élection y avait des nouvelles
élections et françois est dans cette
nouvelle élection pierre-françois bien
l'avait emporté dès le premier tour ça
veut dire que les électeurs n'avaient
pas suivi leur ancien maire de logiciels
est-ce que vous avez aussi cette crainte
c'est peut-être ça qui vous fait hésiter
à vous représenter écoutez vous
m'interrogez sur une autre commune au
message de figure que je ne connaissais
pas très bien de ce que je sais les
quarts
c'est vrai de 15 mois mais sur un nombre
d'électeurs beaucoup plus faible à
l'ancienne donc l'écart
proportionnellement était plus important
à l'ancienne kaka voisins et je crois
que l'élection à été annulée sur un seul
motif
alors que là nous avons de multiples
motifs de violation du code électoral
mais sur le fait que les électeurs par
exemple ou pour ces élections
municipales partielles du ciel ce soit
vraiment plus tourné vers le nouveau
maire élu que vers leur ancien maire et
que du coup il a été élu dès le premier
tour alors qu'elle ait trois listes en
présence
est-ce que du coup ça peut être sujet à
vous faire hésiter août et dont je vais
peut-être le collecteur de voisins vont
pas forcément suivre ma démarche
non vous me demandez si j'hésite ce
n'est pas une hésitation c'est à chaque
fois la même chose je dirais on n'est
pas là pour s'imposer
on est là pour animer une équipe et qui
choisit voilà son sens son chef d'equipe
c'est aussi simple que cela
maintenant chaque cas est particulier
je ne connais pas vraiment les acteurs à
l'ancienne et peut-être qu'il y avait
des circonstances particulières je ne
sais pas quelle va être la saison quel
va être votre programme dans les
prochains jours la consultation avait
écouté on va avoir je l'espère le temps
de dérouler le programme que nous avons
d'ailleurs déjà présenté il ya pas si
longtemps que ça au but chinois
mais certainement en l'agrémentant en
l'adaptant et puis surtout en disant il
nous semble qu'il ya des actions qui ne
vont pas dans le sens actuel de l'équipe
actuelle dans le sens de l'intérêt de la
ville et des habitants pour la qualité
des services sera une liste est ce que
vous serez tête de liste ce qu'on
comprend la ctu aura de toute façon une
liste qui sera soutenu par vous ou
présenté par vous tout à fait d'accord
c'est une information
merci en tout cas à l'équipe d'être venu
merci fois dans quelques instants
alexandra rosetti l'actuel maire de
voisins-le-bretonneux je vous propose
d'abord d'écouter jean h ils étaient
candidat conseiller municipal
d'opposition il était candidat il avait
mené une liste de gauche aux dernières
municipales
il regrette cette situation par principe
je ne commente pas les décisions du
conseil d'état
j'en prends acte c'est tout par contre
ce que je voudrais relever c'est les
conséquences que cela peut avoir pour
les vichy noir des coûts complémentaires
pour les élections du 1 jette des
actions qui étaient en cours et puis pas
de perspective d'avenir immédiate sur
les projets d'aménagement de
construction et c'est donc pour les
chinois c'est assez négatif ou pour moi
c'est une guerre de deggo une guerre de
gens qui sont trop intéressé par eux
mêmes et pour eux mêmes
c'est une guerre qui n'a rien à voir sur
des valeurs
rien à voir sur des programmes ils ont
fait le même programme simplement c'est
pas l'un qui est au pouvoir ou l'autre
et ils se battent pour ça ça n'a aucun
pour moi ça n'a aucun sens et c'est au
contraire une guérilla tout à fait
néfaste pour voir ce que j'espère c'est
que les électeurs vichy noir vont
prendre conscience de cette situation de
l'incertitude que ça a créé et vont se
mobiliser pour élire que des conseillers
municipaux motivé compétents dévoués à
la commune et désintéressé pour eux
mêmes
il y aura une liste de gauche elle n'est
pas encore composer les donc que je vais
vous dire aujourd'hui les électeurs de
voisins-le-bretonneux et bretons n'ont
pas rebondi losio pour élire un nouveau
conseil municipal que pense-t-il de ces
nouvelles élections
c'est la question que nous sommes allés
leur poser ce jeudi voici leurs réponses
que c'est beaucoup d'argent gâché
je trouve que pour quelques voix
franchement c'est beaucoup de bruit pour
pas grand chose
en plus c'est des gens du même parti
pratiquement donc je trouve ça ridicule
je sais pas si c'est vraiment ce qui est
à faire là en ce moment je pense qu'on a
peut-être des choses plus importantes à
faire dans un premier temps mais je
pense surtout que c'est que c'est
dommage de passer par ce genre de choses
que lorsqu'on est déjà fait partir
a priori des la même sensibilité bon ben
on votera mais là je pense que sans
problème
alexandra rossetti passera les doigts
dans le nez parce que je pense que lévis
idoines ne sont pas tous d'accord avec
le recours de biette dans la mesure où
il
ils ne respectent pas le choix
démocratique des vies si noah s'est tous
une bande de truands c'est du cinéma
quoi voilà les propos sont assez de
ferme en tout cas alexandra rosetti
bonsoir de voisins-le-bretonneux d'abord
une réaction sur ces micro trottoir ben
moi je suis assez d'accord parce que je
suis assez triste de ce qui se passe
parce que ça donne une piètre image
effectivement de la classe politique est
aujourd'hui je pense qu'on a vraiment
besoin d'autre chose
donc je suis triste pour ça je suis
triste et même même en colère parce que
je crois que les chinois méritent mieux
que ça ils se sont prononcé il ya un an
je pense qu'on reviendra sur les
accusations de monsieur viet
je pense que les chinois méritent mieux
que ça et que c'est non seulement une
question d'argent mais aussi une
question de projet qui sont complètement
à l'arrêt il faut savoir que pendant
mois et demi peut-être enfin en tout cas
le temps que les élections soient
reconvoquer il y aura un administrateur
temporaire plusieurs administrateurs
temporaire même aux côtés de
l'administration mais qu'en attendant il
nous vous faire que gérer les affaires
courantes et nous avions un certain
nombre de projets engagés et abbas à
bloc des projets d'aménagement en
particulier mais ça bloque aussi des
projets de travaux puisque plus personne
ne pourra passer d'appels d'offres donc
nous avions par exemple les travaux dans
les écoles par exemple de cet été le
temps de rentrer de remettre une équipe
en place nous risquons d'être trop tard
pour lancer ces travaux
on avait également la réflexion de la
petite église de voisins on est dans
plein attributions de la maîtrise
d'oeuvre
ça va être stoppée donc je crois que
beaucoup de choses ont été stoppés je
pense également aux subventions pour les
écoles transplantés qui devait être
votée là donc est ce que certains
enfants ne pourront pas partir dans
l'eure dans leurs sorties scolaires à
cause de ça il y a également toutes les
aides qui attribue le ccrs aux personnes
en difficulté tout ça ne pourra pas être
votée ne pourra pas être géré comme
avaient voté la largue son oui mais ça
met les gens en difficulté
ça va mettre beaucoup de gens en
difficulté pendant un certain temps et
c'est à dire se dire les choses
donc effectivement il ya une question
d'argent aussi parce que re convoquer
des élections et bien c'est un coup
alors pour notre masse salariale qui est
déjà bien au dessus du seuil je dirais
un petit peu classique et puis également
parce que quand on fait une campagne
bien tous les documents de campagne que
nous produisons sont ensuite rembourser
par l'état
voilà donc tout ça est donc supporté par
les contribuables j'aurai comme vous
faire réagir sur la décision du conseil
d'état pas sur l'édition du conseil
d'état parce que la vie est souvent
malgré tout ce que vous avez quand même
quelques regrets aujourd'hui sur le
déroulé le cette campagne sur ce fameux
tract diffusé vendredi par les échos
c'est ce qui vous est en tout cas dans
la décision du conseil d'état reprend un
tract diffusé le 20 le 28 mars entre 17h
et 23h et puis c'est surtout cet appel à
voter pour vous lancer sur facebook le
salat 9 mars vous dites alors honte à
dire là qui vient cet appel ce serait
quand même assez amusant c'est à dire
que je réagis parce que quand on entend
dire sur les choses graves
je vais laisser les vices et moi être
juge de la gravité je peux comprendre le
conseil d'état c'est d'ailleurs s'ils se
déchausser ça ne considérons pas si les
choses avaient été grave ou si grave que
je viens de l'entendre je pense que le
tribunal administratif qui n'est
peut-être pas la plus haute instance de
décision mais qui quand même et gérée
par des gens compétents je pense que le
tribunal mais s'attend intérêt d'achat
conseil d'état n'avait pas géré par des
gens qui ne sont pas compensés à part ça
je veux dire c'est comme pour cinéma
fils younes que la loi considère que
même ses dauphins le tribunal être in
très administratif a jugé que ce n'était
pas grave
d'accord ensuite que le conseil d'état
juge lui que il y est un doute
alors je vais vous expliquer le facebook
c'est ma fille ma fille qui est en
australie qui était en australie à
l'époque en stage australie dix heures
de décalage horaire qui a vécu cette
campagne de très loin et qui postent un
message de soutien sa maman non pas sur
mon facebook qui était fermée parce
qu'effectivement les facebook des
candidats doivent être fermées elle
posté un message sur un facebook qui
s'appelle tué deux voisins si ou té pou
ou de voisins six ou quelque chose comme
ça bref qui en fait est destiné à
d'anciens ici noir c'est à dire que je
ne sais même pas dire combien d'entre
eux sont électeurs à voisins elles
peuvent ce message le samedi soir
effectivement mais dans la totale
ignorance
de l'effet que ça pouvait créer
évidemment elle ne le sache sa visite en
conseil d'état la wimax aujourd'hui
alors grâce à vous ça veut dire qu'on a
estimé que peut-être mais le message
n'est resté qu'une demi heure qu'une
demi heure donc ma fille est quand même
très très doux et 6 1 en une demi-heure
alors réussi à retourner beaucoup
d'électeurs chapeau en tout cas quand je
les sévices hémorragie de la gravité je
rappelle comme qu'une les potins zoua
des cas non moi je teste pas je vous
explique comment expliquer c'est moi ou
victoire au bout 13 janvier de
s'exprimer selon exprimer je veux je
laisse les décinois jugé la gravité
c'est à dire quand on dit que je suis
une tricheuse que ce que je fais très
graves que je ne suis pas digne de
représenter voisins je laisse les
wisigoths à juger de la gravité dans une
grande fille qui envoie un petit message
à sa maman d'australie je n'étais même
pas au courant je dire s'il n'y avait
pas eu de recours j'aurais jamais su
qu'il avait fait ça bon le la deuxième
chose ce fameux tract effectivement
j'avais parfaitement le droit le
distribuer dans les horaires faisait
distribuer le vendredi 7 heures à 23
heures jusqu'à minuit vous heureux la
gorge et reconnu je l'avais distribuer
dans ses horaires là et là où j'ai pêché
par innocence peut-être c'est que comme
dans ce tract je n'attaquais absolument
pas monsieur bien que je ne parlais
absolument pas de lui je ne faisait que
mettre en avant un élément de ma
campagne qui avait été de dire je vais
redynamiser le tissu commercial vie si
noir et dans ce quartier en particulier
ou une supérette a fermé depuis un
certain nombre de quelques années
maintenant et donc gg
j'ai voulu dire ben voilà dans ce
quartier là on va vraiment faire cet
effort là est en fait si vous voulez le
problème d'un élément nouveau
c'était considéré comme nouveau parce
que je l'avais pas écrit comme tel avant
je l'avais dit en réunion publique je
l'avais vous l'avez dit quand je
croisais des gens mais je n'avais pas
vraiment écrit avant donc cet élément
nouveau
monsieur bienne n'a pas pu y répondre
voilà parce qu'effectivement je les
distribue entre alors est-ce que vous
pensez que monsieur biya aurait répondu
à nos noms dans ce quartier on va
sûrement pas rouvrir de supérettes
excusez moi mais non moi je ne suis pas
jésus secondes sébastien cet élément là
pour que les c'est factuel
j'ai la la la décision du conseil d'état
pour dire quand même que et donc je
laisse les vies sinois jugé
gravity de ça et est ce que ça vaut
vraiment la peine après que le conseil
fédéral a fait ça vaut la peine qu'on
peut pas si le conseil d'état après dans
son raisonnement avait quand même fait
une erreur de chiffres donc c'est vrai
que j'avais un petit espoir puisque il
m'avait attribué une progression très
importante dans ce bureau plus
importante que dans les autres alors
qu'en fait c'était ma sixième
progression
donc là on est dans du calcul mais je
peux comprendre qu'on se dise 15 voix
effectivement le doute est permis
c'est la démocratie après tout je veux
dire c'est on a la chance d'être dans un
pays démocratique
mais voilà mais je suis un petit peu en
colère quand même parce que je pense que
j'en ai un petit peu marre en fait de me
faire de faire insulter depuis un an
encore au dernier conseil municipal
l'ancien élu aux finances a traité m'ont
élu aux finances de menteur tricheur
manipulateur
on s'est fait traiter de ce coup on
s'est fait traiter de coucou dans un
livre les échos qui ont du mal à
s'installer
c'est quand même tout dire sur la vision
de monsieur biette de son poste vous et
moi et beaucoup ce sont des oiseaux qui
jette les autres de leurs nombreux cas
une guerre les droits comme un voisin
non il n'ya pas une guerre des droites
ça c'est très réducteur ça c'est un vrai
dire cela c'est ce que la bouge pas
c'est comme regarder on est pas on est
passé pas vers les drones et si vous
prenez ce régulière de vision du monde
c'est vraiment très différent
ça n'a rien à voir avec les partis
habilités tout ça déstabilise quand même
les électeurs voient c'est encore la
guerre je tiens à dire que le foot nous
avait alors avec monsieur viet une
vision du monde et avec nos équipes une
vision du monde totalement différente
c'est à dire que moi je pense que le
pouvoir on peut l'avoir pour les gens et
pas sur les gens voilà alors c'est
peut-être une nuance qui va échapper à
monsieur viet mais je pense que c'est ça
c'est pas droit de gauche dans une ville
comme voisins on est pas on en est pas à
champ de à ce genre de débat qu'est ce
que vous voulez qu'il a donc qu'est ce
qu'ils disent évidemment évidemment
certains béni pour toutes tout ce qu'il
va dire zelaya les prochaines élections
sont pas connues tout le monde parle de
mi avril
on attend évidemment là la notification
de la préfecture ce serait logique
effectivement mi avril
vous êtes en campagne pour les pour les
départementales
vous serez aussi en campagne évidemment
pour ces municipales vous serez la
campagne en même temps la liste il n'y a
aucune ambiguïté je suis d'ailleurs
assez atterré d'entendre que peut-être
que non alors je me dis mais tout ça
pour ça disposez vous votre position et
moi ma position vous serez content et
j'espère bien l'avoir en face de moi ça
veut dire vous regardera dans ces cas là
dedans et dehors en plateau un sens on
verra quand il se sera déclarée mais je
veux dire ça veut dire qu'il n'aurait
pas le courage de se remettre au
suffrage des vies si noah il aurait fait
tous nous en tout cas vous serez
candidat ah bah ça où il ya aucun doute
et merci aux équipes intégralement merci
d'être venu sur ce plateau et nous
ferons de mardi prochain
vous viendrez présenté par andré c oui
merci beaucoup
les soirs aux équipes on continue on va
parler économie
chaque année la banque de france réalise
une enquête sur les résultats des
entreprises et les perspectives de
l'année
une synthèse permettant un aperçu sur la
santé des entreprises
explications avec mélanie poker david
charpentier c'est plutôt l'optimisme qui
ressort de la synthèse sur la santé des
entreprises françaises et notamment
francilienne 777 entreprises
industrielles et 1234 dans les services
marchands ont été consultés par la
banque de france
l'entreprise en 2014 sur l'île de france
on peut considérer qu'elles se sont
plutôt bien comportés notamment dans le
secteur des services et au niveau de
l'industrie
la l'érosion des chiffres d'affaires
qu'on avait constaté par le passé est
toujours dû bloquer quant à l'emploi la
croissance de l'emploi donc à augmenter
assez fortement dans les services on
s'est stabilisée globalement dans
l'industrie dans l'industrie après deux
années consécutives de baisse avec -3 7%
en 2012 et moins 0,6 pour cent en 2013
le chiffre d'affaires en ile de france
s'est stabilisé avec 0 1% de hausse en
du côté des services marchands
l'augmentation est plus conséquente avec
+1 8% pour l'année passée de bons
résultats qui s'expliquent notamment par
la baisse des coûts des matières
premières ou la baisse de l'euro aux
noms aussi donc que les conditions de
financement qui sont aujourd'hui très
bonne pour les entreprises en termes de
tours notamment en france puisque la
plupart des demandes des entreprises que
ce soit pour des crédits de trésorerie
ou des crédits d'investissement sont
aujourd'hui satisfaite par le secteur
bancaire
je considère que l'accès au crédit des
entreprises aujourd'hui il est aisé à de
bonnes conditions
maintenant il est clair que le travail
des banquiers c'est aussi de
sélectionner les risques et donc le
banquier n'a pas vocation à prêter à des
entreprises en difficulté mais c'est
normal puisqu'on lui demande donc lui
aussi à deux d'être capable d'avoir une
activité rentable pour la banque de
france les perspectives 2015 devrait
voir ses améliorations s'accroître à
nouveau une reprise de l'activité est
attendue dans l'industrie du côté des
services marchands les prévisions
devraient être orientés à la hausse le
17 février dernier la cour d'appel de
pareils à annuler l'arbitrage qui a
octroyé 403 millions d'euros à l'as à
l'homme d'affaires bernard tapie sont
accordés en 2008 dans le dossier de
vente d'adidas parmi les opposants à cet
arbitrage
il y avoue dans la khl est bon soir
pourquoi vous êtes professeur des
universités en droit privé à
l'université de versailles saint quentin
vous êtes doyen de la faculté de droit
de sciences politiques à long terme ont
peu de moyens
voilà un horaire d'accord en juin 2013
dans un article paru chez nos confrères
de l'express vous prédisiez que cet
arbitrage sera annulée sur quelle base
vous estimiez que cet arbitrage pourrait
être annulée en fait nous vous aimons
nos produits sur le parvis traces de
leur monde
dès qu'on a eu connaissance de la
sentence est de 7 juillet 2010 lorsque
j'avais été interrogé par l'assemblée
nationale comme bien entendu comme
expert cela s'est fait très vite cet
arbitrage semblait inégal et peut-être
même trop du leu est donc l oms il
faudrait qu'un recours particulier
encore être ordinaire qu'on appelle le
recours en révision puisse être déposée
on veut obtenir l'annulation de
l'entente n'a pas eu beaucoup de temps
il a fallu plus de cinq ans beaucoup de
vos courses déposé c'était le 27 juin
2013 et la cour d'appel s'est prononcée
mardi dernier qui fait que noyer pour
annuler quelques mois par al considérant
qu'elle a été rendue devenu un produit
alors l'arbitrage a été annulé la
question maintenant de l'indemnité est
ce qu'elle doit être restitué si votre
position et ont été très choquées monte
on n'est pas les avocats bernard tapie
qui compte d'ailleurs dans un rôle en
disant qu'une compacte du grand bosquet
et or il n'y a pas de période
et comment à fait délicieux on a voulu
faire simple on a une décision de ces
derniers temps paris qui condamne à une
habilité la décision de justice est elle
même annulé donc la volonté et anisé il
n'y a pas de débat sérieux et d'ailleurs
je crois avoir compris que les
commandements de payer était déjà parti
dès lundi dernier auprès du liquidateur
une dernière session thomas clay si on
sent quand même que c'est un peu le
combat de votre vie professionnelle
moi oui vous a beaucoup entendu sur
cette question d'arbitrage des analyses
qui trouve un expert ils ont plusieurs
effets mais il ya beaucoup d'autres
experts métal et rap c'est pas du tout
le combat de ma vie et de l'arbitrage
critiqué l'arbitrage de ce formidable
exceptionnel qui a été perverti co signé
par cette procédure et que donc il
fallait défendre cet arbitrage est
notamment réputée de vertain qu'en pense
qu'il existe à côté des locaux et
d'ailleurs
le pôle d'excellence de textes et droit
créée justement de droit de l'arbitrage
international
donc je ne voulais pas posé au fond de
l'arbitrage manière générale avait créé
par des trappes
j'en ai pas merci thomas clay en tout
cas d'avoir réagi en direct dans ce
journal on me trouvera plus longuement à
jeudi 5 mars puisque vous serez
invité du journal merci beaucoup au
revoir merci
c'est la fin de cette édition merci de
l'avoir suivi je vous donne rendez vous
demain pour une nouvelle session
d'information nous parlerons notamment
consommation avec mon invité philippe
fleuret du ufc que choisir pouvez
retrouver ce journal en replay sur notre
site internet
bonne soirée